cette journée qui sera marquée par une
intense activité diplomatique joe biden
est arrivé hier soir en europe où il
participe aujourd'hui à trois grands
rendez-vous réunion du g7 réunion dans
la foulée du conseil de l'europe cet
après midi avant cela les chefs d'état
se retrouvent ce matin vous le voyez
pour un sommet de l'otan
le patron de l'alliance atlantique a
rappelé 1 ce matin avant même le début
de la réunion le principal enjeu du
moment écoutez
sourire bing christ nous avons renforcé
notre présence majeure dans la partie
orientale de l'alliance les dirigeants
de l'otan aborderont aujourd'hui la
nécessité de réinitialiser notre
dissuasion et notre défense à plus long
terme 9 ans de longueuil
avoir trouvé tout de suite pour france
24 en direct du siège de l'otan alix le
bourdon alix bonjour on viens de
l'entendre yann sundberg fixé le
principal enjeu un finalement de cette
matinée ce sommet qui devrait être actée
d'un renforcement des troupes tactique
chez tous les voisins de l'ukraine
en effet et puis d'abord l'enjeu pour
joe biden s'est aussi de démontrer
l'unité des alliés face à la russie
depuis le début de cette guerre en
ukraine et puis aussi de redorer l'image
de l'alliance atlantique qui avait été
largement abîmé à vous en souvenez sous
donald trump et puis en effet sur le
plan stratégique le secrétaire général
de l'otan james stoltenberg a donné un
avant-goût des décisions qui pourraient
être prises aujourd'hui elle tourne
principalement en effet autour d'un
renforcement du flanc est l'alliance
prévoit notamment de se positionner
quatre nouveaux groupements tactiques en
bulgarie roumanie hongrie slovaquie et
puis l'on l'otan pourrait également
envoyé des équipements à l'ukraine en
cas d'attaqué chimique une hypothèse qui
changerait totalement la nature du
conflit du conflit d'après james
stoltenberg le secrétaire général de
l'otan ce qui ne sera pas décidée à
priori aujourd'hui c'est la mise en
place d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne a
encore l'envoi d'une mission de paix en
ukraine ce qui mènerait selon l'otan à
une confrontation directe avec la russie
est le principal unique mêmes moyens de
pression utilisés jusqu'ici ce sont les
sanctions économie 4 paquet de sanctions
ont déjà été adoptées vraisemblablement
cet après-midi un cinquième devrait être
validée annoncé
alors en effet ça c'est un sujet qui va
se retrouver sur la table des dirigeants
mais un peu plus tard dans la journée
lors du sommet européen le président
américain souhaiterait que les européens
renforcent leurs sanctions mais vous le
savez sur ce point il n'y a pas de
consensus entre les pays européens il y
a d'un côté les pays de l'est qui
souhaite en effet aller dans ce sens
renforcer les sanctions aient visé le
secteur de l'énergie mais il ya aussi
des pays européens fortement dépendant
des hydrocarbures russes qui préfèrent
temporiser le chancelier allemand
souligné hier qu'un embargo énergétique
avec la russie et bien mènerait tout
simplement l'allemagne à la récession
mais toutes les options sont sur la
table d'après une source diplomatique
alors une idée serait d'imposer des
sanctions sur ce secteur de l'énergie
mais de manière temporaire une autre
piste avancée par les pays de l'est ce
serait de restreindre les voies
routières et maritimes avec la russie en
tout cas toutes ces options seront
discutées
cet après midi et ce soir par les 27
dirigeants lors de ce sommet européen
auquel joe biden vous le savez est
convié merci beaucoup alice le bourdon